that's one theory
mmm I think the most prominent feature
of growing up in Europe anywhere in
Europe is that you're growing up in a
place where people have been
continuously creating culture for quite
a few thousand years so you grow up in a
historical landscape the pressure of
history is on you in every instance when
I was growing up in Rome I used to play
a little game where I would just sit in
any spot in the house in festivities
that we were living in and I could I
would try to imagine the etruscan the
city and then the early Roman city and
then the late Roman city and then the
city at the fall of the Empire and then
the medieval city and the Renaissance
City and all the way up to the present
and it wasn't very difficult all I had
to do was go down in my basement where
there was an Etruscan well and where
people said there were still eels in the
Roman wells and there were also at the
bottom of the building that had been
continuously reading since the Roman era
now whether that was true or not is for
my childhood imagination it was uh it
was very useful and so the idea that you
are living in historical landscape of
that magnitude
first of all makes the sensation of the
dimensions of your own life
rather small and it's an interesting
smallness it makes you feel that you're
participating in an experiment which is
a human experiment which is which is not
so present based and you feel like
you're very much in the way in which
when you go into any Cathedral in Europe
usually cathedrals in Europe or not only
often in Italy built on top of the ruins
or there's not even ruined remnants of a
Greek or Roman temple but the cathedrals
themselves have been continuously
rebuilt and added to over a nine or
hundred or thousand year period you also
feel that all the work being done to
contribute to the making of the
cathedral by hundreds of thousands of
individuals over a period of time is
anonymous work and what you have is this
incredible model that for history which
is the the contributions of many many
people only a few really in any given
great Church Cathedral or signed works
you know there might be a Michelangelo
there might be a team aboard but most of
the work especially the walls of
cathedrals were built by many many many
generations of Mason's fathers passing
the work on two sons and two grandsons
and this feeling of participating in a
human enterprise with that kind of
humility I think is something which I
only experienced in the United States
I only expense the equivalent of in the
United States when I lived out west and
Wyoming and lived in a geologic time
frame so there you know when you're
around places that are like the Grand
Canyon you also have a sense of a
dimension of time which makes your
presence as a human participant in the
temporal sphere of the creation or the
dimensions of the life of the earth
small enough so one of the things that's
a little bit difficult for me is is the
sensation that the present tense of a
single human life is at this moment in
history so magnified and people are so
deeply committed to the belief that
their life in their moment in history
what we would call a very present issed
sensation is very dominant especially in
an urban landscape or there's nothing
too
there's no Sequoia you know there's no
mountain it's very little to correct
your sensation that your individual life
your career your the the development of
your biography in your particular 80
years is the most essential part of your
experience of participating in the life
of the planet